all right let's be clear about something
tonight every state in the United States
is a border state as we speak the Biden
Administration is shipping illegal
aliens all across the country including
one that jumps off the page Tennessee
where according to foxnews.com scores of
single adult illegals are set to be
released pending
Court proceedings here now with more
Tennessee senator Marsha Blackburn
Senator thank you very much for being
here you know we've heard New York and
California and other states right
they're famously in in a Bravado fashion
Sanctuary States come one come on
Tennessee's a different story how did
you find out the Biden Administration is
planning to ship them to Tennessee and
what can you do about it yes indeed the
governor was notified that they were
going to begin to bring these as you
said single adult illegal immigrants
into Tennessee while they wait for their
Court proceeding they're working with
the Tennessee immigration and Refugee
resettlement program and going to put
them in Tennessee now the problem with
this is as you said they're turning
every state into a border state every
town into a Border Town and the Biden
Administration has no plan on how to
deal with this situation at the border
once title 42 goes away so what are they
doing Pete they're going to farm out
they're going to send these individuals
all across the country and say all right
Tennessee or other states you pay the
bill you take care of this because we
the federal government can can't figure
out how to handle this and we have to
move these illegal immigrants from the
border and to other areas where they're
not going to be noticed now in Tennessee
we know it's going to be 50 at a time
they will have at least two buses maybe
more every single week and so far that's
what we know we've written ice but we
haven't gotten a response from them yet
but we're working with the governor
trying to get more information
so 50 at a time multiple times a week
you don't know exactly where yet and
what's the plan drop them off and how
are they sheltered is it on them or is
this just gotta find somewhere else to
move them because they can't all be in
one place or certain States
since the Biden Administration has
broken the border and now we have an
open border and now they're seeing this
surge they have to move them away from
the border so this is their plan send
them to other states send them to other
cities and let the taxpayers in those
cities and in those States foot the bill
for the Social Services the education
all of the health that these immigrants
Sarah was just talking about how abused
these individuals are as they make this
journey this is a humanitarian crisis
and then you also have the issue with
the drugs the exposure to drugs the
fentanyl that people are are
experiencing and the number of services
the amount of services that they're
going to need so this Administration has
shown their disrespect and disregard for
the states they feel like that keeping
the power at the federal level and
having the state to do their bidding
that's the way to handle the mess that
they have made let's let the states mop
this up for us
yeah they don't believe in federalism uh
they they ignore the fact that Tennessee
might have a certain way of wanting to
do things it's a lot different than
California and New York which is why
people are moving to Tennessee in droves
to have that different quality of life
you got it including me by the way
Senator uh Senator Marshall Blackburn
thank you very much for your time
appreciate it hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else